日あっん
ございましたああああああ後輩のお家に
侵入することができました
あっ許可取ってありますいやぁなかなかな
ものが多いなぁけっこうこれ帰ってるなう
これは良くないなでんすけ
怖いの健介
すまんすまないがエアのものなくスマ
30分をずすべての家具を外に出すことが
できました今日は何をしようかといいます
と
ん
おおおおおおおおおおおおお
are you
do とパインダミー300円えへて
いただきました部分ですけどこれだけ部屋
に置いてあるだけでも帰ってきたら
びっくりするんですけどもうこれだけいい
じゃあ
じゃあ水浸します結構か知ってかさー
バラバラでもいいんですけどパメラすべて
きれいな青ロック並べたらなんかそこそこ
すごい感じの部屋になると思います
パイの実の中身を出すと計算したところ1
箱で十条センチかける12cm のでタコ
よりかちょっと大きくなんで結構もうほぼ
全部埋まると思うんですよねこの部屋馬と
して骨ヤルタでは450cm 横が
257cm
タップたぶんこの量で全て埋まると思い
ますというわけで早速やっていきましょー
後輩がお家に帰ってきたら映画愛のみで
隊員の女になっていたやっていきましょう
いうわけに行かれたメットを連れてきまし
たみんなで協力して部屋をパイの実で
いっぱいでしたと思いますいぞ
まずはラップを床に引いていきますそれ
ぐらいするしパケにはいかないので
しっかりと床をキレイにしてからおいて
いきます
ん
んし
衛兵
goo
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
mar
[音楽]
ん
これやばいいよを容易な明日の朝まで
やる気とお願いしまーすって受け入れ
めっちゃ綺麗あっサワー染まる
bme
[音楽]
ですっコメッツけれどねすみませんできな
犬だっけスパーク
ん
me
[音楽]
rar
ブームん
そうだつまんなくなってきちゃっ
たーーーーん
[音楽]
me
ん
キッズマツダ8.感じませ
ブーンああああっ
after
1ん
多分
ん
ああああああああはいそういうわけで
320本なぜ終わりました
全然足りないですねアメリカ200人で
パック第回切ってもらってるんで何として
も部屋を埋めます
e
[音楽]
はいというわけでご覧くださいいろんな
ものがあった怖いの家が体のみになって
しまいましたよね考えが豪遊お金もかかっ
てますし相当の体のみを床に敷き詰めたと
いうことでパットにパイの実ってわから
ないと思うんですよ六角形の機能木材で床
の耐で作られたんじゃないかみたいなこと
を思いそうなのでわかりやすいように愛の
日のパッケージジョー壁にこう置かせて
いただきますこれでもうすぐパイの実だっ
て分かると果たして人は家に帰ってきたら
部屋の中がパイの実になっていたらどう
思うのかさっそく見ていこうと思いますで
は
ん
ポッ
[音楽]
おいおえおはよはよはよ良い
おえおはよー
[音楽]
これはやったねー
ブーブー
[音楽]
エロ
[笑い]
ん先生付
[音楽]
ブーブーのですゲージパネル式だからさ
そうスネアの家具をすべて増加して杯飲み
に行くぞ
じゃああります音でした待って待って待っ
てなんてダメなんていっ